en este vídeo quiero platicar acerca de
las dos formas principales en las cuales
se dividen los triángulos una de ellas
tiene que ver con que tantos lados
iguales tiene el triángulo que es esta
de aquí arriba y la otra tiene que ver
con cómo son sus ángulos que es esta
clasificación de aquí abajo vamos a
empezar con la clasificación de arriba
que tiene que ver con que tantos lados
iguales tiene un triángulo para empezar
un triángulo escaleno es un triángulo en
el cual todos sus lados son diferentes
por ejemplo si tenemos un triángulo más
o menos algo de este estilo donde este
lado mide 3 esté al lado mide 4 y este
lado mide 5 entonces éste sería un
triángulo escaleno porque todos los
lados son distintos pasemos a los
triángulos isósceles en los triángulos
isósceles al menos dos lados son iguales
entonces tendríamos algo así por ejemplo
tendríamos este lado este lado y este
lado de acá lo voy a poner un poco más
bonito
y no sé si este lado mide 3 este lado
mide 3 y este lado mide 2 entonces éste
sería un triángulo isósceles porque este
lado es igual a éste al menos 2 de los
lados son iguales lo voy a indicar con
estas rayitas vale estos dos lados miden
lo mismo y como te hace estar imaginando
y estarías en lo correcto un triángulo
equilátero es un triángulo en el cual
los tres lados miden exactamente lo
mismo por ejemplo podríamos tener un
triángulo equilátero chiquito un
triángulo equilátero chiquito o uno más
grande
no sé pensemos en que en que tal vez los
lados de este son 2 2 y 2 y de este son
4 4 y 4 y en ambos casos serían
triángulos equiláteros los tres lados
son iguales aquí y los tres lados son
iguales acá y aquí me puedes decir a ver
espérame un momento me acabas de decir
que en los isósceles al menos dos lados
son iguales entonces que no sucedería
que que los equilátero son una
clasificación o una situación especial
de los isósceles y si estarías
totalmente en lo correcto todos los
triángulos equiláteros son isósceles
polk porque al menos dos de sus lados
son iguales sin embargo no crea no todos
los triángulos isósceles son equiláteros
este triángulos isósceles porque este
lado es igual a este pero no es
equilátero porque este lado mide
vale sin embargo aquí 2 es igual a 2 al
menos dos lados son iguales 4 es igual a
4 al menos dos lados son iguales vale
bueno esa es la clasificación con
respecto a qué lados son iguales o
cuántos lados son iguales vamos ahora a
la clasificación por ángulos un
triángulo agudo o un triángulo acute
ángulo también se conoce como a cut
ángulo lo voy a poner aquí a cut a
ángulo
es un triángulo en el cual los tres
ángulos que tiene son agudos déjame
dibujar un ejemplo algo más o menos así
algo más o menos así no sé imagínate que
este ángulo de aquí arriba es de 60
grados este de aquí es de 70 grados y
este ángulo de acá es de 50 grados
observa que deben sumar 180 grados 60 y
50 y 110 y 70 y 180 ok bueno un ángulo
como estos en el cual todos los ángulos
son menores a 90 grados se conoce como
un triángulo agudo o bien un triángulo a
cut ángulo vale pasemos ahora a los
triángulos rectángulos en los triángulos
rectángulos tenemos que uno de sus
ángulos tiene que ser recto voy a
dibujarlo nos quedaría más o menos algo
así
algo así entonces un triángulo que se
vea así se conoce como un triángulo
rectángulo porque uno de sus ángulos es
recto es de 90 grados este ángulo es de
90 grados y también se indica con ese
simbolito que puse como un ángulo pero
esquinado que justo se vea como la
esquina de un rectángulo vale entonces
un triángulo rectángulo es aquel donde
dos de sus lados son perpendiculares o
bien eso se puede decir como que uno de
sus ángulos es de 90 grados va y
finalmente un ángulo obtuso o bien
obtusa ángulo lo voy a poner aquí arriba
o tus ángulo este es otro nombre también
lo puedes ver así obtusa ángulo es un
triángulo en el cual uno de sus ángulos
mide más de 90 grados es decir uno de
sus ángulos es obtuso se podría ver más
o menos como algo así no sé imagínate
que este ángulo de acá es de 120 grados
que este de acá es
no sé cuánto le voy a poner digamos 35
grados
eso tendría sentido le voy a poner 25
grados 25 grados entonces este de acá
tendría que ser 35 para que sumen 180 35
y 25 es 60 y 120 de 180 ok entonces un
ángulo octus ángulo es un triángulo tus
ángulo es un triángulo como estos en el
cual uno de los ángulos miden más de 90
grados más de 90 grados y si lo piensas
un poco en realidad sólo uno de los
ángulos puede medir más de 90 grados y
tiene que ver con que la suma de los
ángulos es 180 grados bueno y ahora te
puedes estar preguntando será posible
que un triángulo entre en
clasificaciones mixtas por ejemplo que
sea al mismo tiempo uno de estos y uno
de estos que sea escaleno y rectángulo
pues sí de hecho un triángulo que tenga
medidas 3 4 y 5 por el teorema de
pitágoras que platicamos en otro lado
cumple que es un triángulo rectángulo
que este ángulo de aquí es de 90 grados
entonces existen triángulos escaleno si
rectángulos otra otra observación es no
sé que por ejemplo todos los triángulos
equiláteros son triángulos acute ángulos
porque en los triángulos equiláteros
todos los ángulos son de 60 grados y eso
es menor que 90 grados y por lo tanto
cumplen la definición de ser un
triángulo agudo o acute ángulo vale
entonces se puede tener una gran
combinación de estas clasificaciones
solo cuidando que escojas una de arriba
y una de abajo